>> Raymond: WELCOME BACK TO
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
THE MEDIA OBSESS OVER COVID AND
LARGELY PEACEFUL PROTESTS NEW
CROP OF G.O.P. CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATES ARE ON THE RISE.
THEY AREN’T WHAT YOU’D EXPECT.
TWO OF THEM JOIN US.
FIRST IS MADISON HAWTHORNE,
24-YEAR-OLD WHO WON A BIG UPSET
IN LAST WEEK’S PRIMARY AFTER HE
BEAT THE CANDIDATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ENDORSED FOR
NORTH CAROLINA’S 11TH DISTRICT.
ALSO WITH US HIS FORMER NFL
PLAYER BURGESS THE ONES WHO BEAT
THREE PRIMARY CONTENDERS TO BE
THE NOMINEE FOR UTAH’S FOURTH
DISTRICT.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US.
MADISON, YOU HAVE AN AMAZING
STORY.
YOU COULD WELL BE THE YOUNGEST
CONGRESSMAN IN THE CAPITAL BUT
YOU SUFFERED A TERRIBLE
ACCIDENT, LOST THE USE OF YOUR
LEGS.
WHAT DUDE YOU LEARN FROM THAT
DID IT DRIVE YOU TO WANT TO RUN
FOR CONGRESS?
OF COURSE IT DID, RAYMOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
ON.
MY ACCIDENT TAUGHT ME THE
OBVIOUS LESSON.
I HAD A 1% CHANCE TO LIVE.
I WAS IN THE HOSPITAL FOR OVER A
YEAR BUT THE OBVIOUS LESSONS OF
PERSEVERANCE AND GRIT BUT IT
TAUGHT ME SOMETHING ELSE THAT I
THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
NEEDS, EMPATHY, TO LOOK AT
SOMEONE ELSE WHO MIGHT NOT LOOK
JUST LIKE ME AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THINGS FROM THEIR
VIEWPOINT.
SO I ABSOLUTELY THINK YOU’RE
RIGHT WHEN YOU STATED THERE’S A
NEW BREED OF CANDIDATES.
YOU SAW MY VICTORY AT 66%.
MR. OWENS WITH 43.5%.
IT’S A -- THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS COALESCING AROUND WARRIORS
THEY WANT TO SEND TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO GET RID OF
ITS CRONYISM AND JUST THE SWAMP.
>> Raymond: BURGESS, YOU COULD
FLIP A SEAT FOR THE G.O.P. AND
YOU SAID TODAY THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE FRANTIC THAT THEY ARE LOSING
THE BLACK VOTE.
WHAT DOES YOUR CANDIDACY, HOW
DOES THAT CHANGE THE MATH FOR
THE G.O.P.?
>> ?
>> FIRST OF ALL IT’S EXCITING TO
ME TO HAVE CANDIDATES LIKE
MADISON AND ACROSS OUR COUNTRY
WE HAVE A SPECIAL MOMENT, WE
HAVE A CHANCE FOR A NEW CONGRESS
TO COME IN PLACE.
NEW FRESHMEN THAT ARE PATRIOTS,
NOT POLITICIANS, THAT LOVE OUR
COUNTRY.
AND TO SEE HOW LOVE AMERICA
FIRST LEADERSHIP LOOKS LIKE.
WE NEED TO REPLICATE IT.
I SEE IT IS SIMPLY, AMERICA
ACROSS THE BOARD, WE DON’T TAKE
TWO OF BULLYING.
WE DON’T TAKE FROM THOSE WHO
WANT TO DESTROY OUR NATION AND
CULTURE.
WE STAND UP AND WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A HOUSE OF PATRIOTS, SENATE
WITH MORE BACKBONE AND A
PRESIDENT WHO HAS A CHANCE TO
GOVERN WITHOUT HIS HANDS TIED
BEHIND HIS BACK.
TO AMERICA, STAY OPTIMISTIC.
EVIL WORKS ITS HARDEST BEFORE
THE DAWN.
THEY ARE UNDERSTANDING THEY’RE
ABOUT TO LOSE IT AND THEY CAN’T
STAND SEEING THEIR WORK BEING TA
AWAY BY A PRESIDENT WHO LOVES
OUR COUNTRY AND IS WILLING TO
FIGHT BULLIES.
>> Raymond: THE MEDICINE THE
MEDIA IS CONVINCED THAT THE BEST
PATH TO VICTORY SOCIALLY
DISTANCE DISTANCE THEMSELVES
FROM DONALD TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> WE ARE FOUR MONTHS FROM THE
ELECTION, MAY GIVE REPUBLICANS
COVER TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES.
>> ANY REPUBLICAN ELECTED IS
HAVING TO ANSWER FOR WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DISTANCE
THEMSELVES.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO BE
TRYING TO SURVIVE AND THAT MEANS
-- IF THAT MEANS DROPPING
DONALD TRUMP, THEY WILL DO IT.
>> Raymond: YOU DEFEATED A
TRUMP ENDORSED CANDIDATE
NORTH CAROLINA.
WILL YOU BE RUNNING THE LEADER
OF YOUR PARTY?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I HAVE SAID MY VICTORY, I HAVE
NO REASON TO BELIEVE IT WAS A
REFERENDUM ON DONALD TRUMP.
THERE VOTERS OF WESTERN
NORTH CAROLINA LOOKED AT BOTH
CANDIDATES AND LOOKED AT THE
SITUATION THE COUNTRY IS IN.
THE DIFFERENCE COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR BETWEEN MY OPPONENT AND
THE OPPONENT MR. OWENS IS GOING
UP AGAINST.
THEY WANT ANARCHY AND THEY
WANTED DEFUND THE POLICE WHILE
WE STAND FOR LAW AND ORDER AND
WE BACKUP THE PRESIDENT WHO’S
WILLING TO LEAD US BACK FROM AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME IN OUR
COUNTRY WITH COVID-19 AND RACE
RELATIONS WITH HIS ECONOMY
CRISIS.
IF WE DISTANCE OURSELVES FROM
DONALD TRUMP WE WILL BE DOING
OURSELVES A GREAT DISSERVICE.
>> Raymond: I WANT TO SHOW YOU
WHAT YOU’RE UP AGAINST.
THIS IS CONGRESSWOMAN
SHEILA JACKSON LEE.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THE DISPARITIES
THAT ARE SO STARK THAT ARE
REFLECTIVE OF THE BRUTALITY, THE
CRUELTY, THE FUNDAMENTAL
INJUSTICE AND HUMANITY OF
SLAVERY HAVE NEVER BEEN
ANSWERED.
THIS IS AMERICA’S RESPONSIBILITY
TO PAY THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT’S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY HER DEBT.
>> Raymond: TALKING ABOUT
REPARATIONS.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL HER?
>> LISTENING TO THE VOICE OF A
MARXIST.
LET ME SAY MY GREAT COMMUNITY
THAT I GREW UP IN, IT WAS TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN NOT BY WHITE
SUPREMACISTS BUT BY BLACK
LEADERS LIKE THE ONES YOU JUST
HEARD FROM.
THE BLACK CAUCUS, NAACP.
THE MISERY OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTING.
I’M EXCITED BECAUSE WE HAVE AND
PEOPLE LIKE MADISON AND ACROSS
THE BOARD, WE ARE REMARKABLE
YOUNG FRESHMEN COMING IN AND
WATCH OUT.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE THERE FOR
THE RIGHT REASONS.
NOT TO BE CAREER POLITICIANS ARE
TO BE LOBBYISTS BUT TO GET OUR
COUNTRY BACK.
WE LOVE OUR CULTURE, NATION,
HISTORY AND WERE NOT GOING TO
APOLOGIZE FOR WHO WE ARE.
GET READY.
THE BLACK MARXISTS ARE GOING TO
GO FRANTIC.
>> Raymond: MEDICINE, I HAVE
30 SECONDS.
MARK MEADOWS WHO HAD THE SEAT
YOU’RE SEEKING, HE ENDORSED YOUR
OPPONENT BUT YOU HAVE A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM.
HE WAS YOUR SPEECH AND DEBATE
COACH.
>> HE WAS.
HE DEFINITELY TAUGHT ME HOW TO
BE ABLE TO RIP APART AN ARGUMENT
THAT IS FILLED WITH FALLACIES,
AND THAT’S ALL DEMOCRATS HAVE.
NO HARD FEELINGS.
HE’S BEEN VERY GOOD TO ME MY
ENTIRE LIFE, NOMINATED ME TO THE
UNITED STATES NAVAL ACADEMY.
NO HARD FEELINGS BUT LIKE
MR. OWENS IS SAYING, WE HAVE A
PATRIOT REVOLUTION ON THE RISE.
THE FAR LEFT FRINGE MOVEMENTS,
WE ARE COMING WITH A VENGEANCE
AND WE ARE READY TO FIGHT.
>> Raymond: THANK YOU BOTH.
>> CAN I SAY THIS?
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS,
LISTEN TO WHAT WE ARE SAYING.
WE ARE IN THIS TOGETHER.
DON’T LET THE LEFT TO DIVIDE US.
>> Raymond: GENTLEMEN,
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.